there was literally nothing I can do
doesn't matter how I eat doesn't matter
what I do there's lots of vegans they
get cancer doesn't freaking matter my
diagnosis was a surprise three two one
go so I found a lump in my breast I knew
something was wrong
still I somewhat agree because you like
to think that it's gonna be something
else it's gonna be a cyst it's gonna be
benign
but then when they actually tell you and
you hear those words you have breast
cancer it's like for me I had a
childhood cancer so I was diagnosed when
I was eight and you know I'm a kid I
don't think about this kind of stuff I'm
thinking about you know playing tag with
my friends or going to the movies it was
definitely a shock yeah I definitely
feel the same way back pain and leg pain
only symptoms and we just go to work
being miserable go home online mad my
parents are like you know maybe you
should go to the ER and then we get
there and they do a scan like oh you
have a giant mass in you I'm like okay
great
dating and romantic relationships were
more difficult after my diagnosis three
two one go I had a guy say to me how are
you gonna date guys now you're kind of
damaged goods then you go find him right
like let's go
cancer crew what's up so I mean apart
from the fact that dating in general is
very difficult it's like how am I gonna
find someone who I will not think of it
that way but then he also has to deal
with me thinking that I am that way I
guess I just never really got been into
relationships I guess really the only
light kind of hamper with that is be
like yo I've had cancer like this could
come back like I and
so like I can't have kids anymore right
so like now I have some new hurdles that
somebody now has to deal with with me
I'm actually going to change my answer
after hearing you because I'm in the
exact same boat in Frodo as well like
have children as a result of post being
testicular cancer survivors I often
think about what sorry
I wouldn't think about what what it's
gonna be like now when I you know find
someone when I meet a great woman and
that way I can't you know maybe have
children if she would want children how
would I bring it up and out in a
conversation what I ever I think that
like when someone falls in love with you
they're gonna fall in love with you and
hearing that isn't gonna change it and
if it does they're probably not the
person that you should be with I was
able to find someone really amazing
who's like stuck through all this with
me and like I was bald on tinder being
like who wants this and it's still
really hard like it did make it
difficult to help these relationships
grow I'm also like processing everything
right now
while like formulating this relationship
with someone so it's like a little bit
of a struggle my diagnosis affected my
relationship with my family 3 2 1 go
so it did affect my relationship with my
family but for the better so we became a
lot closer so we went through it as as a
family I was lucky enough to have the
right friends around me and the support
and I'm pretty sure without them I
wouldn't be standing here today for sure
I kind of had a little bit of a
different experience I like pushed
everybody away Oh God okay I'd like
everybody away
throughout my treatment and everything
it's also kind of new because it just
happened about a year ago I'm from Texas
and so my mom like moved moved out here
to come live with live with me during my
treatment and I'm having like a really
hard time connecting with her because I
keep like associating her with that time
so I've also never said that out loud so
sorry I'm getting super emotional right
now but yeah so I feel like there's this
protective barrier on both sides and
having been a survivor and the loved one
of someone had cancer it's I want to
protect you guys from thinking I'm not
gonna make it and from being heard and
from being sad and they want to protect
me from thinking they're worried or god
forbid I would lose hope or anything of
that and so we think we're protecting
each other but we're really creating a
disconnect and I feel like it's long
long after we survive that disconnect is
there we don't go back and become
transparent about what we need to do to
really move forward in life yeah there
was a moment when I thought I wouldn't
survive 3 2 1 go
I mean I think initially with with any
cancer you always think that you know
you're not gonna survive very early on I
was not told you know what the prognosis
was was I gonna be okay what's my
survival percentage and so there was one
very very dark moment for me I tried to
take my own life because I thought that
that was going to be my life from here
on out and I would recommend right now
to anyone who is a cancer patient please
don't do anything like that don't
because I did not have all the
information yet I did not know what was
going to happen or what wasn't can I hug
you
yeah and I think for me is the same
thing it was that dark place in between
diagnosis and not knowing and it was
that I just remember laying in bed
thinking Shh am I gonna die is this it
like I need to take cooking classes in
Italy I haven't seen Niagara Falls I
haven't done the stuff I want to do when
they diagnosed me in the name of the
stage it's to be unfavorable and I'm
like first of all why would you do that
to me like why would you put unfavorable
in the name that's just rude she
explained to me that it was just a
formality just a name like the treatment
you should be responding to it really
well and so going through it I was like
okay you know what I can do this but
then they got to a point in the chemo
that I was like this is what I might not
survive like the cancer okay I was
living in with it for like maybe I don't
know like a year and I seem to been
doing fine man but this chemo is really
making me suffer I have experienced
survivor's guilt three two one go
I could have been born poor I could have
had a different kind of cancer like all
of these different things working
together and I'm not saying that I
shouldn't have survived and I'm not
saying that I didn't work very hard and
my doctors didn't work very hard but on
some level I do feel guilt because there
are so many people who deserve to have
survived and haven't and why is it that
I was chosen to be one of those people
in my second year of treatment I would
have been ten years old
the hospital that I went to had this art
show where all the kids get to paint and
and make some cool drawings and I saw
next door to me there was another photo
but no one was there and reality kind of
sink in and I asked my dad I was like
dad why isn't he here and later that
night he said I don't think he made it
and so I think about that kid every day
I feel bad that I don't remember his
name but I think about his family his
mom who doesn't have a son anymore and
he's never gonna get to go to prom and
graduate college and get the job of his
dreams and have a family and it's that
that one was was pretty tough for me
well I lost my brother he was 32 years
old to cancer but I don't know why his
journey in this life was only 32 years
but I know he did impress a lot of
things and a lot of people in that 32
years I believe that if my brother could
see me and I struggled for a very long
time after losing him that he would have
said the last thing I ever want to see
is you being sad enjoy your life you
don't have to be Wonder Woman like you
just have to live your best life your
happiest life and maybe it's enjoying
pizza and laughing with your friends and
that's your best life have it and love
it
because it's short and and don't don't
miss out on it I am afraid of getting
cancer again 3 2 1 go
so I'm the weirdo so there's a slang
term within the cancer world known as
scan xiety and you know it's when you go
in for a scan you get inside a and
you're like I don't know if cancer is
gonna come back naught or whatever like
I can't change it there was literally
nothing I can do doesn't matter how I
eat doesn't matter what I do doesn't
matter what people tell you there's lots
of vegans they get cancer doesn't
freaking matter so like I just have to
beat it again you know what else am I
gonna do
god you're such a positive person to
hang out with you I think it is just
because I like just finished my
treatment and everything and so I think
that's why it's so scary because like I
haven't even been cancer-free for like a
year yet or anything like that you know
it's just a lot of anxiety but I think
like with time you know kind of like you
guys are saying that it's still kind of
scary but you'll slowly make your way
over there I think that'll happen with
me too
so surviving cancer has made me a
stronger person 3 2 1 go I mean not to
toot my own horn but I would say that I
would have had to have been a strong
person before I feel like surviving
cancer made me realize that that was a
strong person but I don't think it made
me stronger per se I mean I was a strong
person and a passionate person my entire
life but I think it made me even
stronger even less tolerant of pettiness
of drama you know when that kind of
stuff comes up it was like no I don't
have time for that and it made me very
assertive in the fact that if I want to
accomplish this I'm in it right now
I like to think as well that I was
strong before but it's only after you
experience something so life-changing
that you realize how truly strong you
are you know it's no longer what I think
it's how I think
that really puts a smile on my face and
so in that regard it has made me very
strong hey guys thank you so much for
watching that episode of spectrum it's
our last episode of the series for the
year and I want to thank everybody who
came out and participated for sharing
their stories with us and we just want
to say from the whole team
[Music]